more than 20,000 people in Southern
California are under evacuation orders
this morning a powerful rainstorm
threatens to drench areas recently
burned by wildfires and trigger
mudslides flash flood warnings are now
in effect for parts of Santa Barbara
County flood watches are posted across
the state evacuation orders cover areas
northwest of Los Angeles affected by
last month's historic Thomas fire Carter
Evans is in Ventura where heavy rain is
expected Carter good morning good
morning the rain just started and the
problem is it's expected to last all day
it's a big concern for the burn areas
now you can see where crews have put up
this protective barrier here it's not to
keep what's left of this home from
flooding it's to keep all the toxic
material that's in the debris here from
flowing downhill into other homes the
first storm of 2018 is leading to flash
flood watches across Southern California
mudslide conditions are so dangerous
officials ordered mandatory evacuations
of burn areas even before the rain began
it's always worrisome but is definitely
something that you have no control over
the debris flow will be coming down the
street and so we're just kind of putting
an extra berm so it doesn't end up in
the front yard some whose homes survived
the Thomas fire now faced the threat of
not just water in mud but debris left
behind the fires aftermath all those
houses that already burned all the way
down
that's all toxic too so there's stuff is
burnt washing into my house because
Southern California's burn area is so
vast the danger of mudslides spreads
from Santa Barbara to Duarte an expanse
of about a hundred miles when we have
the potential for widespread debris flow
that could impact the same communities
in the same neighborhoods that were
impacted by wildfire we do have to be
aware and prepared to evacuate a lot of
residents in a short amount of time
now officials said they started mentally
preparing for this type of situation as
soon as this fire began back in December
their only hope now is that it doesn't
rain more than forecast Jeff Carter all
right thanks very much